I was in New Orleans for a wedding okay
a fly-in Friday into the Big Easy go to
this place Pascal's manali right and
it's a it's a place where you can get
seafood and seafood you know what that
is man it's different food out of the
ocean or out of water
it almost they say seafood some of the
stuff they serve in Louisiana easily
could have been extradited from a ditch
you know I mean they got some things
like [ __ ] if they catch a dog that can
swim they'll grill that they will grill
that thing up in some places in
Louisiana so the word sea I think is um
you know that could be used or not used
things in water or things from water I
think is more applicable I mean somebody
will grill up a [ __ ] spare tire if
they find you know and call SC food you
know but wet this place Pascal's you
know we hadn't even gotten to the hotel
or motel or wherever we're staying my
buddy and his a flew in my buddy and his
girlfriend flew in on the same flight
I'm dropping them off at their Airbnb
and everybody's hungry we stopped this
place we order some food right we're
sitting there chatting suddenly somebody
across the room starts choking or
choking to death I love you know that's
the thing about choking it's like you
know people it's either I guess it's
either you're choking or you're choking
to death there's not a lot of you know
middle ground when it comes to choking
and this person was choking I guess to
death you know we would we you know it
would take a while still to see so at
that time they were just choking I guess
somebody has to die to be actually
choking to death even though some of the
people like I was choking to death but
they didn't die some of the people say I
was choking to death and if you don't
die you weren't you were just choking
but anyhow that whatever this person is
choking and they stand up and
everybody's just like sitting down like
pretending somebody's not choking maybe
to death and her husband this guy this
this no this lady's
you know she had kind of a I don't have
you ever seen Napoleon Dynamite but
uncle Rico you ever seen that dude his
uncle who could throw the football over
the mountain
she had a haircut like his you know kind
of a like kind of a haircut that had
been blown blow-dried way too long you
ever see somebody there has been
blow-dried way too long and it seems
just lightly not crisped but just it
seems to almost fried a little a little
bit you know air fried not fried by
something wet but fried just by air it
seemed her her hair seemed kind of air
fried anyhow she's choking and her
husband I guess it's trying to help but
he's just like massaging her shoulders
and I'm like what the [ __ ] dude and so
I'm trying to make eye contact with him
before I try to get over there and help
because I don't know if this dude you
know I don't know what their
relationships like maybe he's you know
trying to kill his wife or something I
don't know but I don't want to [ __ ] up
their whole you know whatever they're
trying to do or he's you know if he's if
they're maybe she's horrible to him and
this is you know he you know planned
ahead on this sandwich and this is you
know the the meal that's gonna take her
out you know maybe he can't afford a
cruise you know a lot of people take
their spouse on a cruise and they push
them overboard while they've been
drinking maybe this guy's like you know
I'm gonna save money on a 600 alla
cruise ticket and just hit up this you
know $14 you know owes oyster po'boy
here in New Orleans anyhow so she's
choking this dudes like massaging her
shoulders so I'm I'm like I'm gonna stay
out of this because I don't want to you
know ruin whatever money this dude is
trying to make or you know whatever and
then the waiter comes in everybody else
is just kind of chilling I stand up and
I'm like does anybody know you know
what's going on over here and it's a
small room we're in there's only
probably 13 people in the whole room and
there's about maybe 12 tables and one of
the tables is a five top so I mean this
lady's like spitting and like I don't
have you ever been choking or not
but it's pretty intense have you ever
been like choking - choking possibly to
death that [ __ ] is intense you know and
your face and your your your throat
starts making all this extra saliva you
know you start turning your whole head
turns into like a waterslide I mean you
start dripping out of your eyes and your
nose and everything cuz you're you know
your body's trying to Lube your whole
universe up so you can get this
whatever's inside of you so it'll pop
out and this lady's I mean dripping
she's like crying and his you know
grease coming out her pores and like you
know her ears are like saliva is just
swirling at her ears and everything I
mean she's this lady's lubed up I mean
you think she's ready for some type of
gangbang if she wasn't choking possibly
to death man I tell you dude this this
waiter comes over and he straps on the
Heimlich bro this start this dude straps
on the Heimlich and he was the skinniest
waiter you know I'm not accusing anybody
a different you know you know
extracurricular activities but I've
worked on the pizza line I used to work
and make pizza with a guy on
methamphetamines and then boys can put
in work you know and they don't weigh
much I mean this this dude had this guy
I worked with would wear a belt but he
would have to tie the belt you know in
his what his waist was basically just a
forearm with a spine in it you know in
some organs and some lean organs I mean
this boy was lean and so I've been
around these fellas that's jacked up on
them uppers you know that they call it
high diving you know when you own them
uppers constantly because you live in it
60 feet
you know when it's I mean you your world
is just a bouncy board up there anything
can happen that fall can be fast and and
this is this guy this lean fella starts
doing Heimlich on this lady and this
lady's a you know she's a middleweight
light heavyweight maybe you know she
kind of she's not she's like a Buster
Douglas kind of if you will if you want
to use fight and terminology she she
she's sort of a Buster Douglas and as he
pulls on her his whole
body is coming up off of the ground so
this this guy is Heimlich and this lean
this lean fella dude he's Heimlich an ER
it looked like a skeleton trying to [ __ ]
like a big animal as he's pulling his
his whole body is bucking on her like
his feet are coming up off the ground
his momentum and she's just I mean this
and suddenly there's just kind of like a
like a like that like and just this big
splash of like you know whatever it was
whatever it jacked her system up just
just just kind of just attack it just
flew I mean do a head and liquid flew
out of her eyes nose and mouth
you know the trifecta you know I mean it
was it was artful almost it was
something you'd see at Disneyland around
Suns around sunset when they do the big
water display and the water kind of
jumps from one hold of the other and
they're playing the music you know be
best be best you know and the music's
you know everybody was kung fu fighting
and them just the waters are jumping and
landing in other holes and it's like
this perfect thing it was like that man
it hit the air and it was just like and
just splashed and then everything was
done and it was over and it was awkward
man it was so awkward and I didn't know
what to do so I started a round of
applause because otherwise I'm thinking
here yeah well first of all the lady
lived you know if somebody lives hell
yeah you know even if her husband had a
plan or he was caught up in the dark
arts and his Moraine you know he was
thinking about murder he'd been googling
stuff that was dangerous then would come
back to haunt him you know on a Dateline
episode whatever you know I mean I could
see some you know fella thinking about
taking his wife out via via sandwich
that's an easy that's a $17 kill you
know but
this guy you know I got started this run
of applause as a run of applause going
and and that kind of broke the
awkwardness man and I've been there let
me tell you I have been there okay
I've had reactions if I have and this is
like and I'll know now cuz I'm giving
this secret out to people but if I have
tuna fish and Gatorade same time
just straight tune out the can albacore
you know none of the cheap [ __ ] but if I
go albacore that white meat you know
that front meat that that breast of the
fish immediately if I have that with
Gatorade my throat shuts down I mean
closes up I remember being in a hotel in
Chicago you know I'm hitting myself with
that Gatorade that thirst quencher and
I'm popping off ah I got one of them
bags of cold bags of of tuna fish
because sometime they used to have for a
while and they may still have them
because it's hard to get into a can of
tuna
I mean I remember seeing a homeless guy
beat open a can of tuna with an umbrella
once in Santa Monica and I'm like [ __ ]
that dude you know that's that's
aggressive for some fish you know for
some low-key fish that's aggressive so I
I know that I'm not that kind of guy you
know I'm not that kind of guy I'm not
the guy that beats open a can of tuna
for you know with a with a you know with
a weather prevention utensil
but when when I mixed it so that for a
while they had it in a bag and it was
just a bag you could seal tight you
would open it and you could get to the
tuna right there immediately there's a
tuna it was kind of this metal pouch
pouch does a better term than bag so I
was in my hotel room
I'm running late I just hit the gym I
want to get you know electrolytes and
get my protein in so I hit up a 7-eleven
on the way to my room grab me a bag of
that snack fish that low-key snack fish
and a Gatorade and the Gatorade man
reitman and hit my throat and I had the
tuna in my mouth and throat my [ __ ]
closed up locked so I'm in my hotel room
my [ __ ] is locking locking bro you ever
see like on those movies where somebody
attacks like or somebody you know tries
to think like maybe Star Wars where
somebody tries to get on to the you know
the space vessel and the doors start
closing whenever they're you know
finally are stealing it or whatever in
the the sliding doors are to start
locking down like rush foosh it was like
that I mean my throat started locking I
mean no entry dude I am reaching down my
own throat I don't even ever reach down
your throat for something you know I'm
trying to think what I would compare it
to first of all never would I think I
could get my hand down my throat until I
have to dude I was just trying to hold
my throat open so I could get air in and
out of it man my throat keeps locking I
try to call the phone try to call the
front desk
I can't I'm like going to the hall right
into the hall I had my toothbrush in my
hand cuz I'm trying to push that in my
throat and like hold it to the side to
hold my throat open go into the hall
there's a man dude a man I'm pretty sure
my eyes were watery could have been a
you know I mean it's Chicago it could
have been a lesbian could have been a
hearty lesbian you know you know a
third-degree lesbian and and I am
pulling on this person's pants just
pulling on the front of their pants by
their pockets like on my knees like
basically motioning this toothbrush down
my throat and at first I think the dude
or the I think it's a man now pretty
sure more I remember my memories getting
stronger cuz I have one of those
memories it gets stronger you know some
people memory they gets weaker my memory
gets stronger so I'm pulling on this
man's front pockets and everything and
at first I think he thinks I'm in caught
up in some you know on some cocaine and
I'm probably doing some [ __ ] off a back
page and I'm running some illegalities
you know I'm probably in my room raising
Turtles you know what I'm saying
I'm probably in my room you know making
homemade pesticides and eating [ __ ]
barbiturates soup up in my hotel room
you know I'm probably making bathtub gin
and [ __ ] you know making towels out
of you know a dead woman's hair some he
probably thinks I'm caught up in
something because if you run out into
the hallway and you're motioning the
toothbrush down your throat you know
that has a kind of like an oral sex kind
of vibe to it
and you're crying and everything but
eventually this guy got what was going
on dude and this man is holding a
toothbrush inside of my mouth to keep my
throat open and after about maybe 45
seconds of that it passed it passed bro
and then this dude is like I got a run
and literally took off like I don't know
if he was like ice like a Clark Kent
kind of do that does this [ __ ] you know
it was just wandering around looking for
people to help but he helped me and took
off could not even get his information
could not even get his information man
[ __ ] I could barely get his gender or
sexuality so but so that's what happened
right when I got to New Orleans somebody
was choking to death or possibly to
death and you know and they didn't and
then they sat and they finished eating
they had dessert and they had other
other things snacks you know and I kept
trying to catch the husband's face he
seemed I mean what was he gonna do
massage her shoulders as she died which
would be so awkward
you're dying somebody's giving you like
a nice massage my interested evening
good afternoon and other times thanks
for watching that video you just saw I
mean it was okay but the next video you
can watch could be way better what if
you watch a video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one watch this one watch
this one watch this one